إذا كان عمرك يزيد عن 60 عامًا إذا
كنت تتناول الأسبرين ، فأنت تعلم
أنه لا يجب عليك البدء في
تناول الأسبرين لمنع حدوث نوبة قلبية
أو سكتة دماغية ، فهذا هو
العنوان الرئيسي ولكنهم يقولون أيضًا إن سن
40 40  حتى 59 إذا كان لديك خطر الإصابة
بأمراض القلب أو خطر كبير ، يجب أن
تتحدث مع طبيبك حول
الفوائد واسمح لي أن أخبرك بسرعة كايت
لأنه في كثير من المرات أبلغت عن
هذا السؤال التالي هو كيف
تعرف ما إذا كنت '  إذا كنت معرضًا لخطر كبير أو خطر كبير
بما يكفي لهذا ، فهناك العديد من
حاسبات المخاطر لهذا النوع من الأشياء ،
سنمضي
قدمًا ونعرض هذا على
الشاشة ولكن يجب أن تمضي قدمًا
وتقدير المخاطر بناءً على  امتلك
ملفك الشخصي الخاص بعمرك وجنسك
وأي عمل في الدم من هذا القبيل وبعد ذلك
يمكنك معرفة ما هي مخاطرك
على مدى السنوات العشر القادمة من الإصابة
بأمراض القلب التي سيكون لديك
فكرة أفضل عن المخاطر الخاصة بك ومعرفة
ما هو ذلك  يعني من حيث  من الأسبرين لكنهم
يريدون حقًا الاتصال مرة أخرى ، أعتقد
هنا عدد الأشخاص الذين
تناولوا جرعة منخفضة من الأسبرين لمنع حدوث
نوبة قلبية أولى أو عدم أهمية السكتة الدماغية ،
هذه ليست دراسة أخرى
لا تقلل أو تقلل
من أهمية الدراسات  هذه
نتيجة نهائية توصية نهائية ،
فما الذي يعنيه هذا بالنسبة
لملايين الأشخاص الذين تناولوا الأسبرين
لمحاولة تقليل
مخاطرهم ، نعم هذا سؤال جيد حقًا
لأنك مرة أخرى تتحدث عن هذا ما
يقرب من 30 مليون شخص يقومون بالفرز  من أن
يجدوا أنفسهم في هذا الدلو من الأشخاص
الذين لم يصابوا بنوبة قلبية أو
سكتة دماغية أشخاص يفعلون ذلك
للوقاية وما كان مثيرًا للاهتمام
حول هذا العدد هو أن حوالي
ربع الأشخاص من بين هؤلاء الـ
30 مليونًا تقريبًا أخذوا
الأسبرين بمفردهم بدون
نوع من توصية الطبيب ،
لا توجد إرشادات محددة هنا
أعتقد بوضوح أنهم يقولون إن الأشخاص الذين
تزيد أعمارهم عن 60 عامًا يجب ألا
يأخذوا  أرتينج الأسبرين للوقاية إذا
كنت قد وقعت في تلك التي تعرفها سابقًا
عقدين من 40 إلى 59 عامًا
وأنا أواجه خطر الإصابة بأمراض القلب ،
فعليك التحدث إلى طبيبك
حول ذلك والقيام بحساب المخاطر الذي
يقوله الناس  يبدو أنني في خطر جيد ،
هذا شيء يمكن قياسه كم هي
مخاطرتك حقًا ومن ثم قد يساعدك ذلك في
الواقع على تحقيق التوازن بين فوائد
تناول جرعة منخفضة من الأسبرين
مقابل الوقاية التي يجب أن تضعها في اعتبارك
أنك تعرف أن الناس لديهم  غالبًا ما يقال ، انظر ،
إنه من الأسبرين ، ما مدى
خطورة المشكلة ولكن خطر النزيف خطر
التسبب في نزيف معدي معوي على
وجه الخصوص خطر
النزيف في مكان آخر من جسمك
إذا كان لديك نوع من الصدمة يمكن أن تكون
كبيرة وهذا  يرتفع الخطر
كلما تقدمت في العمر